as leader of the democratic unionist
party on the 28th of may
and as the first minister of northern
ireland at the end of june
it is important to give space over the
next few weeks to the party officers to
allow them to make arrangements
for the election of a new leader and
when elected
i will work with the new leader on
transition arrangements
as first minister it is important that i
complete work on a number of
important issues for northern ireland
alongside other
executive colleagues northern ireland
and its people have been
heavily impacted by the covet 19
pandemic and there remains more work
to do in order to steer us through the
pandemic
and to lessen its impact on the lives of
everyone
it has been the privilege of my life to
serve the people of northern ireland as
their first minister and of course
to represent my home constituency of
fermanagh and south tyrone
i first entered the assembly in 2003
and undoubtedly the journey of this last
18 years
has been memorable there are many people
who have
helped and supported me throughout that
period and i will always be grateful
for the kindness and support shown to me
by them and whilst there have been many
difficult
and testing times for the executive it
remains my firm view
that northern ireland has been better
served having local ministers
at this time it is unthinkable
that we could have faced into the
coronavirus pandemic without
our own devolved ministers in place
and no ministerial direction for
departments
and as i prepare to depart the political
stage it is my view
that if northern ireland is to prosper
then it will only do so
built on the foundations of successful
and durable
devolution that will require continued
hard work
and real determination and courage on
all sides
and whilst the focus is on me today and
i recognize
that that will pass for me the decision
to enter politics was never about party
or person it was about speaking up for
the voiceless
and building a northern ireland which
could prosper
and be at peace within the united
kingdom
i am the first to recognize that there
have been ups
and downs over this last five and a half
years
the 2016 assembly election result and
our party's best ever westminster result
in 2017
do stand out amongst the high points
when the electorate sent
a clear message that they wanted to keep
northern ireland moving forward
the confidence and supply agreement was
able to bring one billion pounds
extra into northern ireland for spending
and our priorities were not narrow but
based on more investment
in mental health hospitals bringing
broadband to rural communities
improving our roads and ensuring funding
to encourage
more shared housing and education
for our innocent victims i am proud that
we've battled together
and while it's truly it for some we
finally secured
a truly deserved pension for you
for our armed forces the veterans
commissioner is in place and you have an
advocate
to stand up for you and ensure your
voice is heard
at the heart of government of course as
with highs
there were lows along the way the three
years without
devolution caused untold harm to our
public services
and the rhi inquiry was a difficult
period
the protocol being fostered upon
northern ireland against the will
of unionists has served to destabilize
northern ireland
in more recent times and whilst there is
still
a job of work to do i am proud that
there is a young generation of
democratic unionists getting involved in
politics
and trying to shape northern ireland for
the better
over the last 12 months i've been
holding online meetings with young
people
mainly from working class communities
and encouraging them
especially the young women to get
involved and i
echo that encouragement today
politics and debate is the only path to
effect change
in society you will and can be
mps mlas and the counselors
of tomorrow my election
as leader of the democratic unionist
party broke a glass ceiling and i am
glad
that i have inspired other women to
enter politics and spurred them on
to getting involved in elected office
and i understand
the misogynistic criticisms that female
public figures have had to take
and sadly it's the same for all women in
public
life so i want to encourage you to keep
going
and don't let the online lunch pub get
you down
to the hundreds of party supporters who
have been in touch
over this past few days i say a sincere
thank you
for the opportunities to serve you and
the support
you have given to me for almost five and
a half years i have been incredibly
humbled
to have the had the opportunity to lead
the democratic unionist party
i have sought to lead the party and
northern ireland away from division
and towards a better path there are
people in northern ireland with a
british identity
others are irish others are northern
irish
others are a mixture of all three and
some are new
and emerging we must all learn
to be generous to each other to live
together
and to share this wonderful country the
future
of unionism and northern ireland
will not be found in division it will
only be found
in sharing this place we are all
privileged
to call home